day 36
kiev is still held by the ukrainians
president zielenski has come out and
said that russians russia's invasion is
at a turning point
but given what's happening on the ground
do you think it is a turning point well
the the short answer is no um i think
language is key here um although kiev
clearly there's an operational pause
around kier for the fighting but
fighting is continuing in the donbass
region which is over here let's just
circle that so we know that and it's
very very uh determined fighting and
likewise in mariopol uh down to the
south
it's pretty obvious that phase one of um
russia's plan didn't go entirely
according to plan um but i think you've
we must never forget that russia is a
global superpower with 10 times the size
of resources whilst zolensky's language
may well be there to raise morale of his
troops there's also no doubt that
ukraine is still in a very difficult
situation and we've yet to see phase two
of russia's plan kick in we're talking
of phase two russia's deputy defense
minister um has said there's going to be
reduced military activity around kiev
and chad here but we have seen
um let me get that we've seen attacks on
shona have haven't we so what do they
mean by reduced military activity well
first of all i would be extremely
cynical about um any russian statement
about their tactics you do not tell your
enemy what you're about to do um one of
the the most effective ways of uh
prosecuting war is through deception and
history is littered with that so i think
we have to take any statement with a
large pinch of salt and it but it may be
that because of the situation around
kiev um part of this is the russians
getting making a virtue out of necessity
because the reality is they've got
forces that are stalled and therefore
and both sides do not want to see kiev
end up the same way as mario paul
flattened so it looks like the russians
priorities across the donbass and to the
south and therefore by liberating troops
by adopting a more defensive posture you
need significantly fewer resources to do
defense than you do offense would get
allow them to re-brigade their resources
that doesn't mean you stop fighting you
store fire mortars you still fire
rockets you still fire artillery because
you still want to keep the enemies head
down it does provide though the
ukrainians the opportunity because now
that this forces are static the ukraine
can now mount counter-attacks and i
think we've been seeing a little bit
more of that the channel for the donbass
unfortunately if you remember the
resupply convoy for keith 40 mile convoy
real problems for russia
in the donbass region they don't have
those problems you're right on the
russian border so resupplying fuel
people ammunition would make life a lot
easier for the russians and of course
also make it a lot more difficult for
the ukrainians now the head of gchq has
been speaking in australia overnight and
has said that um putin massively
misjudged his own capabilities and that
his advisers because the situation is so
dire they're simply not telling him the
truth do you think that he did misjudge
the capabilities and do you think those
people are not telling putin what the
real story is on the ground well i think
there can be little doubt that putin's
initial ambition of just walking in and
being welcomed over 48 hours was folly
so
there's no doubt that they didn't gain
this properly in the west when we're
doing any of these sorts of scales of
operations there's an intense planning
period for the invasion of iraq you get
military leadership they train they
practice they look at courses of action
what's the most dangerous what's the
most likely and then you have a very
animated conversation between the senior
leadership and the political masters to
make sure everybody understands the
risks involved
and then you do lots of training to make
sure your troops are ready it's pretty
evident none of the troops were ready
for this the logistics supply wasn't
ready for this and they didn't really
have a plan b
so for putin who speaks truth to power
how does putin engage with that process
rather than just having a bunch of yes
men charging around in the west
as churchill famously described
democracy as the least worst option but
we do have the press we have the people
we have the military and the politicians
all engaged in a very animated
conversations that when people
go across and start a campaign they're
ready and they are they understand what
happens when the plan doesn't survive
contact it's pretty evident that's not
the case i think the irony of all of
this of course is that putin um the one
thing he was seeking to avoid is what's
coming to him he was seeking to avoid
ukrainian resurgence of their
nationalism um also nato
much stronger and coherent and likewise
the impact long term on his economy not
what he would have expected